this is one of england's last
mountain hares and it has a problem
in spite of all this space in the peak
district
it's running out of places that it can
call
home peak district here we're at
elevation
up to 630 meters it's cold
and wet and it snows in winter these are
the conditions that they're adapted for
and that they enjoy it's a long trek to
find them
and this man is in no doubt that the
biggest threat they face
is climate change we're so privileged
and lucky
that we can come out and see these
arctic species
but here in 30 years time it will be
three degrees
warmer and mountain hares may not be
around
because they do not like it being so
warm they're cold adapted that's what
they prefer they're going to go way up
there
and their range is going to shrink from
about 160 square kilometers
to about 20 square kilometers
they face other threats too scotland has
banned unlicensed culling and their
numbers are doing relatively well
now ministers are examining what more
needs to happen
to protect the two and a half thousand
left
up here i think there's one up there
still yeah this
two up there these
mountain hares date back to the ice age
and they died out in england and wales
as the climate got warmer
then in the late 1800s they were
reintroduced
and these hairs in the peak district are
the only ones that survived
around this time of year the hare's fur
turns brown making them less obvious to
predators
so the changing climate isn't their only
problem
but it could be the one that determines
their survival
lisa dowd sky news derbyshire